t-minus ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one zero and liftoff the
Falcon takes flight propelling the deep
space climate Observatory on a million
mile journey to protect our planet Earth
Ethier that move detection 5.55 gravity
use a beautiful asset
and at 13 seconds after liftoff the
Falcon 9 will reach supersonic speed
50 seconds into flight now
Falcon nine basking in the glow of a
sunset altitude six points five
kilometers average distance 1.3
kilometers be 599 meters per second
recovery has acquisition of signal
standing by to pass through the maximum
diode is on it
Falcon 9 is supersonic
I'd aerodynamic pressure drop the still
nominal everything go on collage remain
nominal Falcon and discover passing
through max Q
and that is killing him
two minutes into the flight of Falcon
personal trajectory altitude 33.9 km/h
get standing by for the first stage
engines to shut down first stage cut off
in about 23 seconds
vehicle remains on nominal trajectory
altitude 57.9 kilometers downrange
distance five zero point zero kilometers
2/3 5 0 meter per second
we have we go on and we have main engine
calibration confirmed second stage
engine ignition and we had Stage two
engine ignition has occurred on time
standing by for the fairing jettison
this will expose discover to space for
the first time and we see here in
jettison
eight minutes 18 seconds into flight
standing by for second stage engine
cutoff we have to go on Easter range
losses signal and Seco 1 second stage
engine cutoff number one has occurred on
time